there we go claims of extortion
blackmail coming from the world's
richest man Jeff Bezos the CEO of Amazon
and the owner of The Washington Post
says the publisher the National Enquirer
threatened to release explicit pictures
of him that Bezos had apparently sent to
his mistress Bezos says the tabloid
offered to hold off publishing the
pictures if he stopped investigating how
the Enquirer obtained text messages that
he exchanged with his lover Bezos
released an email that he says backs up
his blackmail claimed one part reads and
here I'm quoting in the interest of
expediting this situation and with the
Washington Post poised to publish
unsubstantiated rumors of the National
Enquirer initial report I wanted to
describe to you the photos obtained
during our news gathering and quote the
email then goes on to describe the
salacious photos and ends with this this
line it would give us it would give nope
editor pleasure to send this email
I hope common sense can prevail and
quickly and quote the National Enquirer
is parent company says it acted lawfully
and will investigate the claims Bezos
has investigators have not confirmed how
the Inquirer got the text but are
floating this theory they have begun to
believe the Bezos camp that this
publication by the National Inquirer
might have been politically motivated
Gavin de Becker told us that he does not
believe that Jeff Bezos his phone was
hacked
he thinks it's possible that a
government entity might have gotten hold
of his text messages hmm Greg you look
like you're enjoying this story oh yeah
I'm up I support anyone who stands up to
blackmail and it's why you dumb leftists
should stop going after billionaires
because one of the only ways you can
fight extortion is if you're super rich
and you've got nothing to lose three
examples
Peter Thiel right right billionaire
brought down yeah Gawker which was an
engine of malice Donald Trump got the
Daily Telegraph to apologize after
smearing his wife and now you have Bezos
who's a the world's richest man who can
who's actually I always look at this as
somebody who's doing something for other
people meaning that like their lot
people that can't endure extortion
we don't know I don't know what's going
on right now but I know that I couldn't
last it the moment they find me with
that giraffe really interesting you and
yes mine wonders was college and I
needed the money he's trying to
establish a Saudi link and he's trying
to say that David pecker invited to the
White House
he brought a Saudi Hogan pecker is the
boss the the owner of the National
Enquirer and his last name for a very
interesting headline in today's New York
Post by the way a client could you
please explain that to me I wish I
coulda kind of slipped my mind for a
second asking animals are great some
type of Saudi link and maybe
tangentially to the president's that the
president would be behind his affair
with Laura Sanchez it originally started
with The Daily Beast saying that they
were focusing with his personal
investigation on Michael Sanchez the
brother of Laura that started this whole
thing out so he wants to create a
different situation he also goes on to
say that because as soon as I brought up
Saudi Arabia they were frenetic over at
the acquire they wanted to stop this
right away so I hit a nerve and that's
why he came forward so he wants to say
this is an international story when it's
really his personal decision to have an
affair and the pictures were out there
with the Inquirer did know could ever no
one could ever back that out but
evidently it's happening over and over
again capture and kill so and pay me so
Dana you know you handle you handled
public affairs on would have thought
about this because what you get is Gavin
to back with who is the security officer
for Jeff Bezos yep making the suggestion
that we just heard referred to Ron and
so what would you do do you think that
this in fact is as well as Greg said a
man standing up against a blackness
there's something interesting about
billionaires and social media the
ability then to not need a middleman
like a press person right so he just put
it out on medium
like he didn't need a spell put it out
there he didn't even ask he didn't tell
his lawyers that he was going to do it
and so I think that's a very it's very
interesting very powerful way yes and
and also is a way to say like it's also
in some ways respectful to other people
I don't want to deal with the salacious
details I don't bring him to me that
this was your decision to have an affair
this is the consequences are all yours
but I also think it's interesting
because now he has said he said there
are more pictures hmm so if they come
out right I already told you yep there's
more pictures and they're embarrassing
yep that's the case but now as a
National Enquirer where to actually
publish them they'll be on the hook for
the question of were you trying to
extort him they might not ever be
released National Enquirer is on the
hook for a whole lot more Lisa because
they're in an agreement with prosecutors
in terms of the alleged payoffs for porn
stars from Michael Cohen or president
ugly block and then they agreed that
they should not be involved in any kind
of criminal activity while this is found
to be criminal blackmail then they could
be on the hook for that previous
behavior well right I'm not a big fan of
Jeff Bezos but this is a pretty shrewd
move that he's doing because now not
only is he potentially gonna get legal
retribution against the national choir
who published this original story but
you know possible legal trouble and
public relations trouble well they're
calling him an evil and you know what
and to that point exactly so now from a
public relations standpoint he's now
diverted the attention away from his
horrendous story about cheating on his
wife and all this other stuff too now
the national choirs this big bully look
at them and not only that but they're
also trying to take it even further and
lay this at the feet of the president
you've got Gavin de Becker which is the
guy who's running these this
investigation into it was alluded now
somehow that this is the fault of the
the Trump administration that the
government potentially is a government
agency that doesn't mean a USA but you
could imply even more than that because
they've also said that Michael chant
Sanchez was responsible in the
Washington Post reported that he was a
you know a Hollywood agent connected to
Trump so they've now
then try to turn this on Trump who the
media hates is going to take the bait
and run with it
I think it's smart down the Amazon
always about the packages trying to get
out of this segment go